bring the work to the man so that the
man does not have to go to the work
it's the 100 year anniversary of the
moving assembly line and in this office
and in these halls was where the late
Henry Ford began to lay the foundation
of his industrial marvel today his
great-grandson Bill Ford carries out his
legacy it's really amazing that we're
still talking about a century later I
mean you think about most other pieces
of industrial technology or technology
in general and they have they have an
active life of you know a few years
usually at most and here we are a
hundred years later and the assembly
line while it's evolved it's still very
much the same what do you think we're
going to see as far as changes now this
technology affected it at all at all a
lot I mean you personally think of
robotics and coming into the plant and
that technology and there's a lot of
software now being used in plants to
enhance the quality process and the
standardization process but also what
we're building is different in a few
years ago used to have to have a plant
for a vehicle and now with what we call
flexible manufacturing we consult send
multiple vehicles down the same line I
wonder what Henry Ford would think today
if you saw the flexibility to have so
many techniques that kind of improve
upon his original idea one thing I think
he particularly loved is all the new
technology coming into our industry I
think he'd be very excited by that he
was always looking forward
Henri's 100 year old invention not only
changed the way things were built but
the way people lived his mass
manufacturing solution enabled Ford to
pay its employees more and $5 a day wage
was born workers began buying the very
cars that they were assembling where
builders of transportation are the
greatest users of transportation he got
the average person to be able to afford
a car is that still alive today in
today's Ford very much so
but it's interesting going back to what
he did prior to the Model T most people
never traveled more than 25 miles from
home in their entire lifetime
and think about what everyone owning a
car did it really allowed people to
choose where they work where they played
where they lived when it came to the
consumer Henry Ford was not as concerned
what they thought they wanted but
anticipating what they would need
there's a famous quote that he had back
in the day where he said if I'd asked my
customers at the time what they wanted
they would have said a faster horse and
so he was always trying to anticipate
the next great thing and as we think
about a car connected to the cloud we
think about autonomous driving all those
kinds of things I think would have very
much excited him while the modern day
assembly line may have shifted gears of
the past hundred years much of Henry's
original vision remains intact it is
very much back to the future in terms of
Henry Ford